thank you for the invitation to
participate in this
microbiology virtual week
coronaviruses are a family of viruses
that infect vertebrate animals like
birds and mammals
in wild and domestic animals
coronaviruses mainly cause enteric and
respiratory diseases
in humans
they are associated with respiratory
infections
summon ancestors of different
coronavirus genera have been found
in bats living in all continents
from that coronaviruses cross the
species barrier
first to intermediate hosts and then to
humans
that may become a pandemic
the presence of coronaviruses in
ubiquiti's animal reservoirs
makes
the possibility
of new pandemics in the future
a realistic
option
at present seven human
viruses are known
the four in yellow
cause mild respiratory infections like
common colds
some of them 229e and oc43
are known since the 60s
the other three coronaviruses in red
have emerged in the 21st century and all
of them caused pneumonias that can be
deadly in humans
the first sars coronavalios emerged
in china in 2002
from
civic cuts as
the intermediate hosts
it caused an epidemic with 8 000
infections and 800 deaths merce corona
valleys emerged in 2012
in the middle east
and have been causing sporadic
infections from dromedary coming to
humans with the mortality around 30
percent
star scoff 2
has caused the current pandemic
and
its intermediate host
has not yet
identified for the moment
more than 4 million deaths have been
caused worldwide
the possibility of emergence of new
coronaviruses
makes necessary to improve our
preference against future pandemics
coronaviruses are positive strand rna
viruses
with one of the largest known rna
genomes of around 30 000
nucleo
the genomic rna
associated with a nucleocapsid protein
in red
is protected by an envelope that
includes different structural proteins
the membrane propane or m
the envelope protein or e
and the most prominent the spike protein
or s
s protein is responsible for the binding
through the cellular
receptor
and it is also the main inducer of
neutralizing antibodies
for this reason
this protein is the only component of
most of the current vaccines against
sarskoff ii
different vaccine strategies
against sarskoff ii have demonstrated to
be
safe
and efficient
inactivated viruses
are obtained with traditional
technologies
they have limitations in terms of
efficacy
and might have safety problems if
inactivation is not complete
using biotechnology other vaccines
consisting either
in
subunit proteins or in nucleic acids
have been engineered
recombinant proteins are easy to product
and they usually need attributes to
increase efficacy
viral vectors
usually adenoviruses have been
engineered to express
this bs protein from its
genomic dna
they do not replicate in the cells
and they are attenuated
these vaccines have some advantages
just such as the lower cost of
production
and they are easy to store and transport
mrna vaccines are the most
represent the most innovative
technologies
they include
the synthetic mrna coding for the s
protein which is the minimum
inflammation
to produce the antigen inside the cells
the mrna is protected
and delivered
using lipid
nanoparticles these vaccines have
demonstrated to be safe
and highly effective in the real world
however they have some limitations such
as the high cost of production and the
requirements of ultra cold temperatures
for storage and transportation
although
the correlates of protection for
sarskoff ii are not completely known
there is some information
from convalescent stations
about
the conditions of a protective immune
response
igg and iga neutralizing antibodies
against vs protein have been found in
almost all the patients
in addition
to a cell response against the s-protein
interestingly
cd4 and cd8 t-cells
specified against epitopes present in m
n and non-structural proteins were also
found
indicating that
other vital proteins in addition to
s-protein are also required
to get a protective immune response
mrna things have important advantages
first safety
mrna cannot be integrated into genomic
dna
so there is no potential risk of
mutations
an rna is degraded by cellular rnases
its half life
in vivo is short
so there is no
risk
of toxicity by over expression
of the protein of interest the s protein
they contain a few chemically defined
components which simplifies the
regulatory process
rna vaccines have demonstrated to be
highly
efficient
and
the expression of rna
requires optimization of
stability and translation
career molecules are required for the
efficient in vivo delivery of mrna
although large scale production of mrna
vaccines is feasible
it's more economical options should be
welcome in addition to the current
non-replicating synthetic and rna
vaccines
virus derive
self-replicating rnas
represent promising next-generation
vaccine candidates
they have been optimized by viral
evolution
in terms of replication gene expression
and evasion from the innate immune
response
today i will present
our work
in the development
of cell replicating rna vaccine
candidates against sars2
in our laboratory we have been working
in coronaviruses for more than 35 years
we are interested in the identification
of virus virulence factor
deletion of these genes from the viral
genome
leads to attenuation
and
attenuated
viruses are vaccine candidates on the
other hand the identification of viral
and cell pathways involved in
pathogenesis
provides information about
potential therapeutic targets for
antivirus
working with highly pathogenic
coronaviruses
requires biosafety level 3 protocols and
laboratories
as this one shown in this picture it
corresponds to our
laboratory at the national center of
biotechnology in madrid in spain
to a study viral pathogenesis and to
develop vaccines we have established two
essential tools
first an infectious dna clone
this is a full-length dna copy of the
viral rna genome
which can be modified in the lab
using molecular biology techniques
we were the first lab in the world in
the year 2000 to develop a reverse
genetic system for coronaviruses
which was challenging at that time
because of the large size
of the viral genome
and because of the presence of toxic
regions for bacteria
and second small animal models that
reproduce the severe disease
observed in humans
they are critical to evaluate the
efficacy of vaccines and antivirals
precontinence viruses can be rescued
from the infectious cdna clone which is
assembled by joining
synthetic dna fragments
this cdna clone
is
introduced in bacterial artificial
chromosomes
which are transfected into mammalian
cells
rna polymerases from
these cells transcribes
the dna
into
an rna molecule which is identical to
the genomic rna of viruses
this rna starts
the virus life cycle
leading to infectious viruses that can
be rescued from the supernatant of the
cells
genetically modified humanized mouse
models
that express the human receptor of the
virus
reproduce the infection
of the lungs
clinical signs
including the inflammatory pathology
and pulmonary pathology and finally the
death
in the last few years we have been
working in the development of mers
chronovirus rna replicant as vaccine
candidates
which are replication competence and
propagation defective
these results are the proof of principle
for the development of vaccine
candidates against starscoff2
using the reverse genetic system
a deletion mutant of merged coronavirus
lacking the envelope or e protein was
generated
this deletion mutant
was propagation defective as shown
in the
left graph
with the red line
this delicious mutant was propagation
defective which means that it was lost
during passages in cell cultures
in contrast to the continuous growth of
the wild-type virus as shown with the
black line
by providing entrance the e-protein in
packaging cell lines
the growth of the
defective virus is partially rescued
these
viruses are replication competence as
shown
in the right graph
the red columns show that
they produce viral genomic and
subgenomic rnas to similar levels at the
wild type values as shown in the blue
columns
since they have lost its ability to
propagate
they are not viruses anymore and they
should be considered
just as rna replicants
these rna replicants are produced
from the engineered
dna replicant in packaging cell lines
which provides the missing e-protein in
trans
other
vital structural proteins are produced
from the self-replicating rna
to form
virus-like particles
that include
the viral rna
the replicant the rna of the replicant
to be delivered to target cells
inside the cells
rna replicants
produce
amplify its rna
and produce the
proteins the antigenic proteins of the
virus
and form these virus-like particles
which are antigenically similar to the
wild side virus shown to the left
this
provides
an improved immune response because
these virus-like particles not only
contain the spike protein but but also
other vital proteins which are essential
to improve the immune response
however
these viruses like particles are
defective in propagation
because in target cells the e-protein
is missing
which makes the replicant viruses highly
safe
the attenuation of the rna replicants
was further increased by the deletion of
accessory genes
is genes are not essential for viral
replication in cell culture
but they are involved in virus vigilance
in vivo
because they interfere with the innate
immune response therefore
deletion of these genes increases the
innate immune response
and as a consequence also the adaptive
immune response
nurse coronavirus
encodes four axis origins three for a
for b
and five
to illustrate the contribution of
accessory genes to virulence the
deletion mutant mers delta 4b
neared and evaluated in humanized mice
for clinical signs weight loss and
mortality
merge delta 4b as shown in the red line
caused an initial weight loss
that was in
followed by a recovery
in contrast
to the severe weight loss produced by
the wild-type virus the black line
as a result
all wild type infected animals died as
shown to the right
in the black line
while
animals infected with the delta 4b virus
the red line to the right
all of them survived
indicating that forbidding was a
virulence factor
and delta 4b values was attenuated in
vivo
attenuation of merge delta 4b virus was
associated with a decrease in the
igniting mean response
as observed in the red columns
corresponding to delta 4b values
lower levels of pro-inflammatory
cytokines like il-6
and chemokines
were observed in the lungs of mice
infected with delta 4b values as
compared to the wild-type virus
corresponding to the black columns
although both viruses replicated to
similar extent
in addition to rna replicants lacking
one gene be eating essential for
propagation
or for accessory genes
involved in
a vigilance corresponding to the the
second
skin in the
slide
another rna replicant
was generated including a deletion of
the two sets of genes
this rna replicant lacking five things
was replication competence and
propagation defective
it was self-replicating because includes
the replication machinery
indicated by the blue
boxes
and
this
self-amplifies viral antigens and the
antigenic dose including not only the s
protein but multiple viral antigens
like
games m
and a non-structural proteins included
in the replicase
which improves the immune response
in addition it is
highly safe because it lacks
genes essential for propagation like
eating
and all the accessory genes involved in
vivulance
the attenuation of mars agony replicants
was evaluated
in humanized miles
in contrast to the wild type virus
please
see the black line corresponding to the
wild type virus
which cause severe weight loss to the
left
and the death of all the animals to the
right
rna replicants lacking either eating
in green
or for accessory beans in red
or the five genes in orange
this and this mice did not show any
clinical signs
and all the animals survived
indicating that rna replicants were
attenuated in vivo
the replicant lacking
five genes the access origins and the
envelope gene
was
replication competent in vivo
as shown by the orange columns
indicating the synthesis
of genomic rna to the left
or subgenomics rna to the right
although to a lower extent than the wild
side values in the black columns as
expected
these replicants lacking
e and the accessory genes was
propagation deficient in vivo
as observed in the orange columns
no infectious virus
was
detected in the lung
of a
infected mice as compared to the
efficient production of infectious
particles around
millions of infectious particles
observed
when the animals were infected with the
wild type values as observed in the
black columns
protection
of a
mice
induced by
merge rna replicants
was
studied by the intranasal immunization
of humanized mice
with a single dose of rna replicants
followed by the challenge with the
lethal dose of mers
wild-type virus
as observed
in the great line non-immunized animals
showed
a severe weight loss
after the challenge and all the animals
died
in contrast in the colored lines
animals
immunized with the rna replicants
did not show any clinical signs or
weight loss after the challenge and all
the animals survived
indicating that immunization with the
rna replicants lacking
1 4 or the five teens provided one
hundred percent protection to the
immunized animals
interestingly
the immunization
provided by the replicants
was sterilizing
as observed in the orange columns
indicating that no
challenging virus
was detected in the lungs of immunized
mice
in contrast
through the effected effective growth of
the challenged virus in non-immunized
mice as shown in these black columns
this sterilizing immunity not only
protects against the disease
but also against infection and
transmission
this is a
concept corresponding to an ideal
vaccine
carbon vaccines provide an efficient
protection
especially against disease and death
but they not provide
an effective protection against
infection and vital transmission
so
the idea of getting and sterilizing
immunity
is an an interesting concept for next
generation vaccine candidates
following a similar strategy to that
used with merged coronaviruses we are
currently working in the development of
the vaccine candidates against sarskoff
ii
also consistent in consisting in
replication competent propagation
deficient rna replicants
starting from the infectious cdna clone
of stars coronavirus as shown in the
first line
a collection of deletion mutants
of sarskoff 2
have been generating
and
replication competence propagation
decisions rna replicants have been
obtained
by
the deletion of a combination of genes
which are required for propagation and
also involved in virulence
two formulations are being assayed for
the delivery of the rna replicants of
starscof2
to the right
the strategy of values like particles
similar to that
described former score anaviruses
the dna coding for the rna replicant is
transfected into packaging cell lines
which provide in trans
those structural proteins necessary for
propagation
two generate virus-like particles that
include
the rna replicant inside
in target cells in immunized animals
these vlts
introduce the replicant rna but in the
absence
of the proteins required for replication
there is no possibility of generation of
infectious viruses and only the rna
inside the cell
self replicates and produce
the antigens necessary for eliciting an
effective immune response
the second strategy consists in
synthetic
self-free
delivery system
the rna of the replicants is produced by
in vitro transcription and combined with
polymers
to form nanoparticles
in addition
to the intramuscular
immunization we are also working in the
international administration of these
rna vaccine candidates
because an
international immunization leads to
mucosal immunity which is essential to
provide
sterilizing immunity and to get this um
protection that not only protects
against disease and death but also
against
vital transmission
and finally the acknowledgement to all
the lab members participating in this
project especially to luis and juanes
who started the coronavirus laboratory
in madrid
many years ago and to our collaborators
and of course to all of you for your
attention thank you very much